Joining me today as a lawyer or a gun
rights activists and the host of know
are on NRA TV.
Kalia.
No,
are welcome to the Rubin report.
How's it going?
How's it going,
my friend?
It's going good.
It's good to be in la.
I am.
I'm glad to have you on.
We've been trying to do this for about a
year.
Yeah,
you're a busy man.
I just don't like to think so.
It might just be a facade I put her onto
avoid people,
but no one actually were in reality now
it's been.
It's been a pretty busy year.
Yeah.
Like extremely so.
And it doesn't ever seem to slow up and
just want to think it does.
Something else jumps off.
Well,
if you think coming out of this show is
gonna help slow it down.
You are sorely mistaken.
Yeah.
Well I'm a bit of a masochist in that
regard,
so we'll see.
We'll see by the time this hour he's
done work on earth.
Hell,
we can release you.
I'm pretty sure there will be some.
Yeah.
Well,
don't worry because there will be equal
amounts of me just sitting here with
you.
That's the interesting thing.
You know,
I don't want to say I've been blind to
it,
but just being.
Just seeing some of the reaction and the
responses that I got,
especially like for instance when I was
on radar when I.
After I did Bill Maher,
I still saw some of the comments from
the like I say the other side just for
ease of communication,
but for people who largely don't agree
with me and his audience and he was
like,
oh,
why would drive the NRA guy on there?
Even a,
it was a tweet I responded to yesterday
and even though I was on my no tweeting
deal that I like to put my cell phone
because so toxic and they're sometimes.
How often do you do that?
Every 30 minutes.
I'm trying to do weekends disappearing
and all of August see it man.
Twitter's toxic man.
When you're in the lane that you and I
are and it's toxic man and it can
really.
Even though you don't think you're
taking that in,
even when you just kind of scrolling
through,
you're taking that in.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's like I constantly have to
develop this pattern of just,
you don't respond to that because
they're baiting you and things of that
nature.
But um,
I,
I saw a tweet and she's like,
yeah,
I love,
Oh,
I love this episode,
but you have that NRA guy on there.
I'm like,
Jesus,
are we not allowed to have discourse
anymore if it,
especially if it disagrees with
something that you believe in and,
you know,
and I was like,
this is a very dangerous road we're
going down if that's,
if that's going to be the case because
you forget,
you know,
we live in this country together and
we're not all the same.
There's about 350 million might not all
think the same thing.
Exactly.
Pretty crazy.
It's,
it's kind of sad.
So it,
at least for me,
it's a little disheartening because I
grew up under the guise and
understanding the importance of
discourse and being able to talk things
out even if you do disagree with
someone.
But then they even still having the
ability to set aside whatever views I
may have on a particular issue and then
be able to speak with you cordially or
have respect for you even though we
don't agree that's the way I was brought
up.
And so to see the country kind of
falling into this extremely vitriolic
divisiveness it,
it's heartening to know me get all emo
on you,
but it does it like we don't have to
guess cried until the end.
We can do it this way.
But.
But that's exactly why I wanted to have
you on because you are okay going into
enemy territory.
I'm not calling this enemy territory,
but you did,
you did Maurice Show where you knew a
certain percentage of the audience was
just going to hate you.
And we talked about it briefly right
before we started,
but you found Martin to basically
pretty,
pretty respected.
Even kill.
Yeah.
Even though I'm policy,
he probably disagrees with you with 80,
80 percent of this tournaments.
Yeah.
And,
and,
you know,
and it was something that I ended up
respecting about him in that regard
because like I said,
I kind of,
I went in prepared for,
I didn't go into dual war,
but I went and prepared for it,
you know,
it was like prepare for the worst,
hope for the best.
Um,
and I tell you I got the best in a sense
of it was a,
it was a discourse where he challenged
me,
but it wasn't this kind of tumultuous
kind of butting of heads where it was
just turned into something that was just
ugly.
Yeah.
He,
well,
he wasn't trying to get.
Yeah.
Trying to understand you because that,
that,
you know,
I'm trying to do that here.
I think there's a couple other places
where people are trying to do that.
But yeah,
that's the thing that's been lost.
And that's an interesting thing you
pointed out there.
It's,
I think sometimes people take offense to
that idea.
It's like,
well,
I don't want to intrude.
Intriguing.
I think intrigued kind of offense people
sometimes because it's like we all grow
up with a typical understanding of what
we expect certain people to be like and
then when certain things don't fit,
it's like,
hmm,
that's interesting.
How did you get there?
Right.
And I think when it's innocent like
that,
I don't think there's an issue there
when you use it to try to kind of muscle
people into believing a certain thing
based on what they are,
then that's when we start having
problems.
You know what I mean?
It's like you see me as like how to you
as a black guy.
Like it happened to me when I first
started doing what I did with the NRA.
I'm a Russell Simmons or,
and I'll never forget this.
I was like,
I was like in Virginia Beach,
I think.
Um,
and Russell said,
I,
I did my first sets of videos rolled out
with the NRA and I get this tweet from
Russell Simmons.
And he was like,
how can you as a young black man push
data,
you know,
the typical rhetoric in that regard,
even though he often is all about trying
to get people to.
Exactly.
Which was really odd.
And so I,
you know,
I responded,
I said,
you know,
like I didn't know advocating for self
defense and self reliance was a bad
thing.
I didn't know that only non black people
were allowed to do that.
And so that was Kinda like my first
foray into that world of wait a minute.
People have an expectation of me based
on my race that I'm not going to say I
was oblivious to,
but it just,
when it was coming from people that look
like me as well with the same level of
intensity,
that's when I go wow.
Okay.
Alright.
So here,
that's what this is.
Yeah.
So I want,
I want to back up a little bit of
childhood and growing up because you're
evolutions kind.
Interesting.
But let,
let's just sit with this for one second
because I think there's something really
interesting about that thing right there
that often if you listened to the media,
they'll you that that police are hunting
down,
black men are and all of this,
and then at the same time you're saying,
well,
we should be able to arm ourselves and
protect ourselves from the white
supremacists.
See whoever is doing that,
but meaning that lawfully and legally we
should be able to take care of
ourselves.
If you believe that the system is so
corrupt and the police are so corrupt
and there's racists running around
everywhere,
you're trying to bring the power back to
yourself.
That's to me,
that's very empowering.
Yet somehow this seemingly is lost.
When this conversation hits the
mainstream,
it's amazing.
I don't understand it.
It's like in one breath you're talking
about let's,
let's take the current administration
for instance,
they'll paint it as this the most
vicious involving on the planet,
and then it's like,
well then let's give the same guns that
you have for your own self reliance.
Would you would use to protect yourself
against this monster that you said
existed and let's give it to them and
then place your entire alliance with
respect to your safety on the same
people you,
you're telling me I should be scared of.
It doesn't look horrible.
Give them your weapons.
What again?
Just it's,
it's mindblowing.
Right?
And so what it does though,
it exposes this notion that the,
there's an absence of ability to,
I don't want to say mobility or people
just choosing not to critically think.
And we're at a point now where we have
access and I tell people it's like,
it amazes me some of the questions that
I get and it's like you literally have a
device that gives you access to all of
the information in the world and it's in
your pocket.
And in the case of my overabundant
tasks,
I have two of them and it's like it
takes you to fall into your.
I assume you have like eight guns on you
at all.
Those rifles,
some here.
So you know.
And it's,
it's amazing how when we have such
access to so much information,
we've become so lazy at reaching for it.
This was almost like back in the day
when we didn't have this access,
we were more adamant about search
searching and seeking it out and
critically thinking about things.
It's almost,
we've become too fast for our own good.
Right.
So the obsession now is instant
information,
instant information regardless of
whether or not the information is of any
use or good or the or if it's even
correct.
Yeah.
You know.
And so it's it.
I hate it because,
you know,
I,
I blogged,
I've done all of those things and
actually get people get mad at me when I
don't jump on a certain issue quick
enough.
And when I say quick enough,
within 30 seconds,
the second I'll see that sometimes
something goes down in the news and
literally two minutes go by her,
I'm at dinner and I wasn't living at
home.
And then I'll get a slew of tweets.
People.
Well I see you didn't comment on that.
You must be in and God paid off.
God forbid it involves a black person
and there's a gun within 10 miles.
I have to jump on it.
Yeah.
And in some cases I understand there's
some people who do who are just now
getting into this who are just now
getting into firearms and they are
black.
Right.
And you know,
they look to me for understanding and
direction because I've been doing it for
so long so that I understand,
but,
but other people,
it's just this constant desire to be
like,
ah,
I got you.
I knew you were coon kind of deal.
Right.
And it's like,
like,
give me 30 seconds to even read the
article you just sent me 10 seconds ago.
Yeah.
Right.
And then from there,
and then not to mention,
you know,
there's this thing called work that I
do.
So yeah,
I'm still doing that as well.
So I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm juggling a lot of things.
I think I don't have to tell you,
you probably have to read 10 more
articles to even ascertain anything
close to the truth.
Bingo.
And that's the one thing that I think a
lot of people don't do.
And almost tweeted that the other day I
go,
you know,
it's very dangerous to read headlines,
especially in the day and age of
clickbait titles,
to just read headlines and then make an
opinion based off of that or think you
know,
understand what happened at a particular
story because there are so many articles
that I've read about me and what I've
said where the headline said one thing
and to cover their assets within the
article.
They'll clarify exactly what,
what it is that I said,
but they're banking on the idea that
people are just going to read the
headlines and then run with that and so
it ends up making a fool of you in full
of people.
What's your personal policy on that?
About how to respond to that?
Do you go all in on the fight?
Do you ignore it?
Because that this has happened to me
just in the last week.
Daily be said,
I was all right.
Cheerleader.
Now,
correct me if I'm wrong,
if you're black.
I think so how am I doing for the.
For an orange,
you suck now.
Well,
no,
I mean,
but this is the level of pity,
but then it's about how much time do you
want to invest in,
in defending yourself and by doing that
defense,
do you just add intensity to the people
going,
I see we can get them to defend himself
and then before you know it,
your whole life is dedicated to
defending yourself from fake attacks
rather than you and the work that you
care about.
Two things.
One,
they do it to you because you're
dangerous.
You're dangerous.
Not Because you agree with me in
certain,
in certain issues,
you're dangerous and the fact that
you're just simply willing to talk to
me.
So for instance,
same thing happened when I did.
I did the interview with killer Mike,
Right?
They jumped all over him,
not because of what he said,
but just because he sat down and had the
conversation with me.
Half the time they don't even listen.
Oh,
that's interesting.
You can point it out because I was
talking to my friend.
I'm like,
how can anyone watch this interview and
not walk away with saying,
you know,
that was a great conversation about two
people who don't agree on everything,
but there's some things we agree on
like,
because they don't watch it.
That sounds like.
What do you mean?
It's like I had just this weird blonde
moment,
right?
Yeah.
I'm like,
what do you mean?
He was like,
they didn't watch it.
they don't actually watch the video.
They just read the title and then assume
they know what happened in the video and
then make their opinion from there.
And I'm like,
damn,
you're right.
I hate going down in the weeds with too
much in this because it feels like we're
just responding to all of the craziness.
But even in the.
Even in like the youtube ecosystem when
we put videos up,
sometimes within 10 there's 100 condoms
and that was an hour of want,
that time when she can,
because I will be a lot more productive,
but it's always the haters that that's
why I wouldn't bring it up because it.
Because then that heat is the thing
that's always leading us and then I
think that brings it back to where you
started a moment ago,
which is that we're in this polarized
thing and it's because the haters are
are sort of paving the road and everyone
else is just going down the road.
I think a few of us are actually trying
to better road that.
More of us can get it.
The interesting thing about the
discourse the way it is now,
right?
And so our politics have become our
entertainment.
That's the one that's the dangerous
aspect,
right?
So if it's not vitriolic,
if it's not snarky,
if it's not any of those things,
if people don't pay attention to it.
And I'm the biggest advocate of like,
all right,
look,
if you,
if you don't agree with me on something,
you don't have to be an ass about it
right now.
Can I be snarky?
Hell yeah.
No,
I,
I can absolutely be snarky,
but what I,
what I tried to do in response to your
initial question,
you asked me how do I like,
how do I go all in?
Do I respond?
So like for instance on twitter,
what I've kind of held myself back to
doing now is if I can tell that the
person is literally seeking out an
answer or response,
that's I'm going to give them that same
energy in terms of,
okay,
no,
let's,
let's have that conversation.
Right?
Because there was a point in time where
everything I responded to when I respond
to it through the lens of just being
this snarky on,
you know what I mean?
And Yeah,
sure,
it was entertaining myself.
Absolutely.
But then I had to ask myself was I
really moving the conversation and the
dialogue along,
even though it is twitter,
it's twitter,
it's a dumpster fire,
but when I started has some importance,
does just the truth.
That's why it keeps coming up in so many
of these conversations that high level
people with great minds that are open
and engaging,
that are still involved in the stupidity
of that.
So it's like I always feel guilty when I
bring it up with a guest.
I'm was like,
I don't want to touch that again.
And then on the other hand,
we all know it's really just,
it just is whether we want it to be or
nothing,
like you said,
whether we like,
Nah,
this the medium of expression right now.
Um,
and so we have to either adapt or die,
you know,
but,
it's,
I try,
I try to be what it is.
I tried to be the opposite of what I
could plan about.
At least I try in terms of like,
sometimes I'll see snarky messages and
then I'll respond by trying to be
reasonable.
I say,
okay,
I get it.
You don't like me,
but answer this question for me.
And I tried to move the dialogue along,
you know,
what ends up happening to get deleted.
Yeah.
Almost every single time.
The second you shed a little light on
it.
Grad scatter.
Yeah.
Yup.
What,
what is the,
uh,
before we dive too much into your past,
what is the thing that they're
criticizing you most for?
Like you come across to me as a pretty
rational,
decent,
open guy.
You're trying to empower yourself.
Okay.
So what is it that they're always going
after you?
Is it that thing that black men
shouldn't be for guns?
I mean,
is it that simply stupid?
So I'm like,
so I don't,
I'm not going to be so naive to assume
it's simply just because I'm black and
I'm in the guns and holds up.
That's part of it.
That's a big part of it is just aligning
myself in the organization that they
seemingly,
that they see as being a racist
organization that hates black people.
And we're going to talk plenty about the
NRA.
Right?
So there's that element of it,
but then there's,
there is also this idea that being a
young black man that I am supposed to
run from guns because of the projected
image that we've all had forced down our
throats with respect to black men and
firearms in this country for decades.
You know,
black man with a gun,
he's a thug.
He's a drug dealer.
He was a gang banger period.
So now when I young,
attorney educated,
open minded and you know,
with respect to different issues and
then I'm pushing the narrative of the
second amendment,
it sets off an explosive level of
cognitive dissonance in people who have
what I love this quote and I believe was
Bush who said it,
the soft bigotry of low expectations,
right?
And it,
they hate it,
they hate it the same way they,
they hate you now because you can't
control someone who's willing to think
independently outside of what is
stereotypically expected of you.
Right?
Um,
and that's where the labels come in and
so it's like,
Yo,
do progressive or liberal,
you know,
so,
but you still have that ability to step
outside of that and say,
you know what,
let me let me.
Okay,
I can see that perspective.
That's dangerous for people who want to
control people.
So when I want to control the way you
think,
the way you see yourself,
I cannot allow you to develop it and
ability to think independently on
separate issues because then I can't
control you.
So if I,
if I say,
you know what,
I can do everything for you,
depend on me.
The last thing I want you to do and
understand this,
you know what,
wait a minute.
You mean to tell me I could protect
myself.
You mean to tell me I don't have to
depend on calling a cop in order to come
save me if someone does try to break
into my house because then I can't
control you.
I can't own your vote because what the
gun has done for me and a lot of people
it serves as a catalyst for awakening
for a lot of people don't understand,
you know,
what I can do more for myself than I
realize,
you know,
and once that,
once that spark is set off than a lot of
things,
you start to realize,
you know,
I don't,
what maybe,
you know,
not on,
I'm holding myself to a different level
of accountability.
Maybe I might try to do this on my own,
you know,
just feel good and they put an aside.
I know a lot of people are into facts
over feelings these days,
but Shapiro but doesn't that statement
right there that,
that you can do more for yourself.
It just feels good like pills,
making some power back to yourself and
go and the government or you,
whoever you are or are not in charge of
my life,
my responsibility,
my livelihood,
my family,
the rest of it.
It's the most invigorating feeling in
the world.
And I'm with you.
I'm all about facts over feelings and
I'm meaning from standpoint.
I don't allow my feelings to dictate the
facts,
you know,
I do think feelings are necessary,
right?
Because we would,
in the absence of them,
we just become cold,
calculated creatures.
Right.
And we are still human.
We are getting,
you know what I mean?
So it's like now at least.
So you know,
when I talk about the issue of firearms,
I do actively try to inquire.
I was,
I was having a discussion with a lady
not too long ago about just general
firearm issues with respect to her son.
Right?
Who's the young black man.
And I asked her,
you know,
like the,
are you fearful of the idea of him
carrying a gun and so forth and so on,
and I have to bring myself back when I'm
having a discussion with someone like
that because I don't have kids.
Right.
So Yeah,
and my godfather that,
yeah.
So,
and,
and I,
and I love her but it's not the same for
a woman who has a son.
So I have to be cognizant of that and
understand what goes into that when
she's thinking about whether or not she,
he,
she is okay with him owning a firearm.
And then on top of that having this idea
that her son is more likely to get
killed by a cop because he has a gun on
him versus when he doesn't,
you know.
And that's where the feeling component
comes in where it's necessary.
I think if you can't sympathize with
that,
then it makes you dismissive.
And so then that person can't relate to
you,
then we can have that conversation.
You know what I mean?
And that comes from personal experience
because when I was reading your bio
there,
I mean,
it's really interesting stuff about how
you evolve sort of politically and
personally,
but when you started getting into guns
you kind of had to hide it from your mom
either.
So everyone actually takes a little bit
about,
about growing up and then sort of your
kind of politics and then how do we,
how do we get so into gun director?
So I've,
I grew up largely a closet anti gunner.
I didn't realize I was going the wall,
there was one president,
right?
I wasn't kind of rapidly running out,
running out,
screaming.
I hate guns or anything like that.
But when a woman was president,
I remember there's one moment when I was
in college,
I had a roommate,
um,
when their friends brought a gun over,
I was like,
you need to get the hell out my part.
You get the hell out of my apartment.
And um,
had a good friend of mine who randomly
just asked me,
hey,
do you want to go to the range?
Never even thought about it.
Never even crossed my mind.
Which is how I know a lot of times I can
decipher based on certain comments
whether or not somebody is actually
coming from a place of ignorance or a
place of understanding because I was
that guy never even thought about going
to range,
never thought about shooting gun,
but I can tell you all their opinions on
the world wide.
Right?
And so when I hear that rhetoric now I
can usually point it out and I'm like,
you've never shopped before.
You've never even held a gun before.
And so from that perspective,
we went to the gun range and shot for
the first time and I was hooked.
Now I was hooked not from a political
standpoint now with not even from an
empowering,
oh my God,
I can protect myself now standpoint,
it was just pure fascination with the
mechanics,
the physics,
all of it.
I'm a very kind of like,
curious mind.
So for me it was like kind of like this,
like the idea that I'm launching a
project out faster than the speed of
sound and a little target 100 yards
away.
Like that was awesome.
So first shot you were hooked,
first shot terrified me the second,
so a little bit second shot.
Right,
right.
Um,
so from that perspective,
after,
so after that,
I just,
I follow that rabbit all the way down
the hall,
but it was,
like I said,
it was more from a scientific,
mechanical understanding of it.
Then as time went on,
then I started looking at it from more
intellectual,
second amendment political activist
standpoint and then I started my,
then the lawyer mind kicked in and then
I started looking.
I'm like,
I'm hearing something.
We [inaudible] we during the time
period.
Then that particular time period we had
a couple of pretty big mass shootings
that happened and so I started paying it
and so now I'm paying attention more to
this kind of like when you're thinking
about buying a car and you never see it
on the road.
And then once you start thinking about
buying you see it everywhere.
That was pretty much what happened now.
So I'm like,
I'm hearing the conversation about guns
everywhere now and I'm like,
none of this is making any sense
logically like what people are
proposing.
It doesn't.
It was so pure,
it wasn't like an agenda driven.
I was like,
this doesn't make sense to me.
It's like a window,
like a sticker on the window,
not going to stop somebody from bringing
a gun in there saying that it's illegal.
You need the dad's not going to read the
sign and be like,
oh exactly.
I go to the other place.
Right.
So interesting.
That's Kinda when I started jumping into
the more activist advocate side effects,
um,
with respect to the second amendment.
And when you first got guns.
Yeah.
You were literally hiding them from your
mind.
Cause cause,
cause she was very much let me,
she was a single parent mom raising a
black son.
She wanted to court every stereotype on
the planet.
Right.
My mom over compensated with me
tremendously because she understood,
she understood in her mind the
limitations that come with being a
woman,
raising a man by herself.
So she overcompensated.
So whereas usually typically have like
mama's boys who were just kind of like,
mom does everything for her.
She ain't did shit for me.
Go wash your own clothes,
come here and go do shit.
Like everything she made me and I didn't
at the time I just thought she was just
being,
I mean not realizing,
you know,
it was her overcompensating standpoint.
It's like I gotta make this through.
I got to raise a man.
Yeah.
Right.
And so,
but so she was trying to buck.
So I knew once I started getting into
guns.
No,
no,
no.
Because the perception was black man
with gun gang banger.
Right.
And you know,
she had some insecurities in that.
She's like,
you know,
like there's gonna come a point where
I'm not gonna be able to control this
kid.
I don't know what it's going to be
doing.
And so I didn't want to terrify her and
make her think that I was living in the
ferris lifestyle,
that she.
And it was almost in a way to protect
her more than once to hide it from
myself because I didn't want her to feel
like she,
like she failed as a mother and so I
knew if she saw the AK 47 that I had
hidden under my bed.
In her mind she knows nothing about
guns.
All she knows is what she sees in the
media.
And we all were like we touched upon
before,
that imagery is not positive.
So she comes home,
sees ak 47 in bed.
She's,
Oh my God,
my son is a gay man first instead under
the bad guy.
You said in the bed.
Is there anything you want tell here
we're talking about that.
Like,
I already did this.
I did this guy.
Both basketball fans.
I used to sleep with my basketball.
Oh yeah.
Oh Man.
Yeah I bought was life that was
everything out.
And you still got any skills?
Some,
some something.
Something.
I'm actually working on trying to open
next.
NRA annual meetings put together like a
to a charity.
Basketball it.
If you're down.
Can I get into that?
Let's do it.
Alright.
Let's do it,
but uh,
I've never slept with my guns.
Right.
Okay.
So,
so from that point when you started
getting okay with this and now you're
exploring it,
as you said intellectually,
uh,
how long before you were really an
advocate for this stuff because you
always sort of wanted to fight for
something to be a theme with you.
A long time.
It was def that that's what I wanted to
do.
I wanted to be an advocate.
I wanted to be in the courtroom
defending people.
That's,
that was my goal.
Like even to the detriment of my grades.
Like I focused more on like my mock
trial stuff when I was in law school
than I did my actual work,
like the,
like schoolwise,
right.
And um,
I liked being the voice for people.
I like being able to speak to people who
can articulate certain things away that
maybe I can.
And I never saw this going way that it
did,
but I'm doing exactly what I always
wanted to do.
And,
and for me with the gun thing,
I remember being in like I'd be in class
in law school and the way that they,
like the seats are staggered or like
stadium seats,
right?
So if I'm on my computer and you're
behind me,
you can see what I'm doing on my
computer and I'd be in class in like I'm
researching guns and all man,
God,
dude,
like people.
And the thing is a lot of things that
were being said about me I didn't even
know about till later on,
people were concerned.
Yeah,
I really like Yo.
It's like he's like,
he's not crazy.
He's not,
you know,
um,
and I get it if you don't,
if you're not into that kind of thing,
um,
and you don't follow it.
The idea of being passionate about
something you perceive to be a tool that
you use for killing people and only
killing people.
It's gonna seem new to you.
But because I came to it so naturally,
so organically without any of that,
it just made sense in my mind.
I was so unapologetic about it.
Once I got over being apologetic about
it,
that I didn't push it in people's faces,
but you know,
there was a,
there was even a time like that's how my
instagram got started was me separating.
So the people who followed me up until
that point,
you know,
I had a girlfriend at the time was like,
I get a lot of questions where people
can tend to tone down the gun stuff a
little bit.
And it was,
it was kind of an innocent thing,
but I never really.
I just said,
you know,
what,
forget it.
I'm just going to set up a whole nother
page and now I'm just going to do all
the good stuff I want to do on that
page.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and now that's taken over.
I don't even use the other one that I
don't even know if I remember the
password,
but it.
So from there,
that's where things really started
taking off.
And then with the and,
and then when I started I started doing
gun reviews.
And so then from there when I got into
the political component of it,
then I started talking during my
commentary and then that's when things
started really taking off.
All right,
so let's do this.
I want to do gun one on one with all the
things that we should know about guns.
And then I want to do the most common
misconceptions about guns.
Because I think part of the issue right
now is every time something happens,
every time there's a shooting,
half the people don't know anything
about guns.
On one hand,
half the people then give you all of
those misconceptions.
It gets confusing for everybody.
And even the people who I generally
trust,
I,
I don't know exactly what they're
saying.
So I want to do a video with you right
now.
Every time one of these incidences
happen and someone starts asking me
this,
asking me that I want to go,
I've got the thing that I can point to
with the answers.
So let's do gun.
What on what?
What do we need to know about guns are
first and foremost,
ar does not stand for assault rifle.
So when they say ar 15,
that's not assault rifle,
does not mean assault rifle.
And the assault rifle is a gun that is
fully automatic,
right?
That means I pulled the trigger,
I hold it back and an expense all of the
ammunition in the magazine.
So that's Jesse,
Ventura and Predator.
Boom.
Okay.
It's a great gun.
Yeah.
Love that guy.
I can argue that not going to side with
my known again.
But um,
so,
so that's automatic.
You just hold it down and down and it
will fire every round,
uh,
subsequently until it's completely out.
Okay.
Right.
And does.
So at a very high rate of speed.
Generally speaking,
somebody automatic.
So now there's been this thing where
people conflate this or use somebody
automatic as a kind of a hyperbolic way
of characterizing guns as death killing
machines,
right?
Virtually every modern gun is
semiautomatic.
And what that means is one press of the
trigger,
one bullet versus holding the trigger
down once and getting all the bullets.
Okay.
So that's a great distinction out there
because often when this happens,
you see people saying we have to band
semiautomatics semiautomatic.
That's virtually every month.
He's just because all the,
the only difference between that and a
what I guess fully automatic stuff.
Well what's one that you're just loading
one bullet in that.
Okay.
So that would be a bolt action.
Right.
So there's fully automatic,
semi automatic and Bolt Action Bolt
action more.
It was more like to like,
like hunting,
right or high high precision shooting
and it's a bolt because it allows you to
build a gun up in such a way where you
at the tighter constraints within a gun
and allows you to be more accurate
without certain mechanism moving back
and forth causing.
Throwing off the accuracy of the shot.
So you would say then that when with all
of these people come out and say we have
to band semiautomatics and that they are
actually just flat out confused or
intentionally conflating or a
obfuscating what the truth is related to
them?
Yes,
absolutely.
And so it's either they're confused,
they're ignorant or they're doing a
purposeful that you just stated.
Okay,
so what is the.
So let's do some nra stuff while we're.
While we're doing this,
what is the NRA stance on automatics
just being able to hold an shoot.
I mean,
the way it's currently regulated is the
way it stands right now.
There's like in order to get an
automatic gun,
there's a certain process you have to go
through in order to get them.
And it's been that way for a very long
time now and that's been that it exists
as it does now.
And that's essentially where the stance
is with respect to fully automatic
what's,
what are people using fully automatic
guns for?
So um,
because I think this is where you'll
hear people go,
well,
no one needs an automatic to see.
Here's the thing though,
it's the idea of putting it under the
guise of needing,
right,
their name,
another right where we use that same
standard,
you know,
begs the question.
And so it's like,
okay,
you haven't fully automatic gun and you
have some automatic gun shot bolt
action.
There are different reasons why you
would want each of these guns.
Now I can delve into that.
But then that starts getting into the
very nerdy side of firearm ownership.
Whether enthusiasm aspect of that comes
into it,
it's understanding tactically why you
would want certain things.
And so for me,
I'm not personally,
I don't have a problem with people on
fully automatic gun personally.
I just don't see that as a significant
danger above and beyond say owning a
nuclear suitcase.
Right?
So people tried to make that absurd
argument to me before.
It's like,
well then why don't you read a lot and
well that's because there's a,
there's a cost benefit ratio that
doesn't make any sense,
right?
That you just inherently self
destruction.
So how is,
how is that protecting you in any way
from the very thing that you're supposed
to be taking yourself against?
Do you think there should be a higher
threshold to be able to get an automatic
than some of the other records you're
talking about?
Me Personally?
Threshold in what respect?
Like in terms of either hire back graded
background checks or references.
So.
So talking about background checks for a
minute.
So there's this idea,
this notion that we don't have
background checks for guns.
We do.
And the funny thing is we,
in the gun community,
you become become a victim of
technology.
And what I mean by that is people think
that just because I can go into a gun,
if I really wanted to,
I can go a gun store right now,
buy a gun within two minutes just like
that.
You can.
Yeah,
because you've done all of the
background and see that's the thing
though.
I'm still going under.
I'm undergoing the same processes.
So I go into a store,
I find a gun.
I liked this gut.
I say I want to buy this gun.
I fill out the 44,
a forum,
44 slash 73,
which asked me a series of questions.
Then they take that information and they
submit it to the FBI database and they
do a background check,
but it happens instantly because
technology people.
It's interesting because there's a lot
of people who feel,
like I said,
undergo some type of CIA investigation
before I buy a gun.
The same people who also hate the
government.
Exactly right.
So when they did the instant aspect of
the background check causes people who
don't know very much about the process
that think that there isn't one.
Right.
Just because I can buy the gun easily
doesn't mean it was done thoroughly.
You know what I'm saying?
I underwent the background check.
There's a system there.
They checked it against the system.
If I don't have any felonies or anything
that prevents me from owning a firearm,
I'm allowed to buy the gun.
Okay.
So when people say there are,
there are no background checks and
background checks aren't tight enough or
however you want to extrapolate that.
Is there any credence to any of that
that you can.
So now let's talk.
So I think what you're,
what you're kind of going into is
universal background checks,
right?
So when they say universal back,
now they do conflate these
terminologies.
There's universal background check is a
very specific statement.
It's not like saying coke,
right?
Because people here universal background
checks and all the.
Here's the background check part.
That universal means something.
And what that means is it's a
requirement that every single
transaction you have to undergo a
background check,
even private transactions.
Right?
So right now in California,
if I had a gun,
right,
I can bring a gun into California,
just can't carry it.
But you were like,
hey,
you know what,
cause I like that gun.
You have right one to buy it from you in
California.
I can't sell it to you right now.
What?
Here's what I can do.
I can say,
all right,
cool.
When I get back to Texas,
I'll transfer the gun to a gun store
here in California if it's on a specific
list that allows you to actually own
that gun,
right?
Because California has the district.
Yeah.
And then you would have to go to the gun
store and then buy it right now.
Let's say I decided to give you the gun
anyway.
Privately,
right now in this room,
no one else is here.
But you went on and I saw the either
gun.
You want me to shut the cameras and I
don't have any plans on going to jail.
And I sell you the gun.
You know,
and then let's say you have the gun,
what is there to check against?
What databases did they check against to
determine whether or not you got a
background check for that gun?
Now,
just completely two issues right now,
so.
Well if we did it on the dl there,
there's no,
there's no way and that's what the whole
concept of the universal background
check is.
It is to require a background check for
every private transaction.
Now,
legally right now I can't do it,
but like in Texas I can sell a gun to a
friend and as long as I know he's not a
prohibited person and I know he's not a
felon,
I can sell him that gun.
No problem.
That's completely legal with the
universal background check idea suggests
is I should have actually,
he should be required to undergo a
background check before I can sell in
that gun.
That would mean you and he and I would
have to go to a gun store and undergo a
background check.
Then he can go and buy the gun from me.
So is the problem with the way it is
currently saying in Texas,
the way you're describing that you just
would not know intentionally enough
about the person you were selling it to
a potential?
Absolutely.
And so the reason why I'm against the
universal background check is because
there is no other way to enforce it,
but for a national gun registry,
because otherwise you have nothing to
check it against to say if a cop walks
down the street sees you have a gun and
he's like,
did you get a background check for the
gun?
Yeah.
How's he going to prove otherwise?
Unless there's a national registry and
then there was,
okay,
fine.
Or then let's have a national registry.
No,
because we've seen time and time again
that when the governments have a
national registered firearms,
they subsequently use it to confiscate
guns.
Now the problem is when you say that
they try to put the tin foil hat on you,
right?
Except because what they.
What they envision is roaring truck,
black military trucks coming down the
street pulling guns from people's
houses.
No,
that's not what happens or how they do
it.
It's constructive and then when you have
potential presidential candidates like
Hillary Clinton suggesting we should
take apart,
we should take up the Australia model,
which did that very thing.
They use the national,
they use a national gun registration to
tell people to say,
you know what,
you need to turn in your guns.
It's a voluntary buyback.
No,
it's an.
It's a,
it's a mandatory buyback.
Right,
so,
and if you don't sell your guns back,
guess what?
You go to jail.
That's a confiscation.
It's a constructive confiscation,
but compensation nonetheless,
just because they didn't roll the
military trucks down the street and pull
them out of your house doesn't mean it
isn't confiscation.
And so that's why I'm.
I'm adamantly against universal
background checks unless you can
demonstrate away from it for it to be
applied in such a way that would not
require a gun registry because I do not
trust my government not to exploit that
registry in their favor.
Yeah.
So how much of this then,
because we've talked about it,
you said to me right before we started,
you're sort of a libertarian.
I think it's exactly what he said.
I don't want to put words in your mouth.
How much of this does go back to that
states should be able to make the
decisions that they see fit.
I mean,
I suspect you probably wouldn't be that
thrilled living in California other than
the weather.
I.
I'm here in California.
Whether the women.
That's pretty good.
Food and texting.
Yeah,
we do.
Yeah.
I'm not complaining about that.
I'm so.
See.
That's just it too.
It's like,
well,
how far those states' rights go from the
standpoint of violating my second
amendment.
Right,
right.
I believe in states rights,
right?
Them to point.
You started violating my constitutional
ones and so when you have places like
California,
which I think I think I'm being
currently violated now,
the fact that I can't carry my gun,
what is the difference I can take?
I can take my car with my Texas license
and drive it right into California.
No one has a problem with that.
I can drive up and down these roads and
as fast as I want,
as recklessly as I want.
Yeah,
that might be illegal,
but I can still do it.
Does that potentially to do it,
but yet I can't carry the thing that I
carry to protect my life with the same
license.
That doesn't make sense to me.
Like am I any in any less danger here
than I would be in Texas.
If anything I can make the argument that
I'm more.
There's more danger for me here in that
I don't know the area very well.
So in a weird way,
you're actually making a non states'
rights argument here,
right?
Because if you're saying you want the
same thing everywhere,
that's not a states' rights argument.
It's not that,
but that's what I'm saying,
but that's under the guise of me feeling
like me not being able to carry his
violation of my constitutional right.
Right.
Because there's rights doesn't allow
them to violate those constitutional
rights and that's,
that's the argument I'm making now.
It's difficult because when you start
talking about the idea of having a
uniform like concealed carry platform,
right?
Where one license allows you to carry a
gun everywhere,
right?
Then you start getting into the weeds
about,
okay,
well that's violating states rights,
but that's only if you don't see my
ability to carry your firearm as a,
as a,
I'm sorry,
uh,
my ability to carry a firearm as a
violation of my constitutional rights.
Right.
So it's a,
it's an interesting philosophical place
to talk because it's like,
it just depends where you start because
even though I'm definitely a states'
rights guy,
I hear what you say there.
And then on the other hand,
as a state's rights guy,
to me,
if a state wants to have stricter laws
and you're a big gun guy,
then you actually are allowed to leave.
It's kind of it as I would say for
virtually every other situation.
It's kind of shitty.
It doesn't feel great to have to leave a
place that you want to be at,
but if they are doing things as part of
their state experiment that you don't
like well on,
it's on you to get going.
Yeah.
But if that same state creates a law
that violates my right to privacy,
right?
Well we have constitutional rights
superseded.
So I see.
So I get,
I get nature.
Are we missing anything else on the
technical front because we did that
pretty well.
I'm sure we will see a from a mechanical
standpoint just from a mechanical
standpoint or just any of the language
that we use related to this.
Okay.
So yeah,
so then of course there's,
some people can say it's trivial.
Some people say it's not.
So the magazine versus clip,
the general terms.
Actually it's called the magazine a clip
is an actual thing.
It's just different from a magazine but
that's kind of slightly trivial,
but it,
it does typically kind of expose people
who don't really know much about guns
when you say clip versus magazine
because the proper terminology would be
magazine.
Um,
as far as any other mechanical
components,
what,
what do I need to know about the
magazine?
Well,
that's just terminology.
It is semantics,
right?
Get this.
I don't always go about correcting
people because I felt like it just
creates it.
It kind of makes me look like an ass,
but that's why we're doing this.
I don't want to clean up.
The biggest thing is just the assault
weapon thing,
right?
Because the Ar 15 is the civilian
weapon.
It's,
it's designated.
The biggest difference between an ar 15
and an assault rifle is that the assault
rifles,
fully automatic and they are 15,
isn't it?
That's the biggest distinction between
the two.
Now,
of course,
then you can make the argument.
Well that's some very minor distinction.
You know,
there's a lot of people who make that
argument,
but I don't look at the Ar 15 any
differently than I look at the handgun
in that sense.
Okay.
So every time when one of these happens
and we hear the Ar 15 is a weapon of war
and so were handguns,
you would basically put the Ar 15 of the
handgun in the same categories as
pulling ones.
Yeah,
she even wants.
Yeah.
So that would not be categorized as a,
as a weapon of war will see that.
See that estimation,
that terminology is designed to,
to manipulate the emotions of people who
don't know anything about guns.
So when you hear,
if you don't know anything about
firearms and you hear he used a weapon
of war,
technically speaking our guns or weapons
right?
So words can be weapons.
Exactly.
So,
but what that does mentally,
like they understand language very well
and they liked our unit,
but in terms of the,
I call it the anti gun side of it,
I things they understand the use of
language very well and um,
and they confuse it purposely.
So when you hear someone who doesn't
know anything about firearms,
think about it.
Like if,
if I'm already kind of,
I'm a little scared of firearms and then
I hear he used a weapon of war.
What image comes up in your mind at
it's,
it's Rambo,
he's running down,
they're just going crazy and that's
exactly what he's doing.
He could do the same thing with a
handgun.
And so the biggest thing that I like to,
when I'm having these conversations with
people's,
you're going to walk away with,
we're going to walk away with two with
two points of two trains of thoughts.
I'm even going to get you to admit you
just want to ban all guns or you can see
my perspective because if you're,
if you're willing to say,
you know what,
we need to get rid of all the assault
weapons as they,
as they understand them to be,
which is essentially a fifteens,
but now it's actually become even more
broader.
Like we need to get rid of all
semiautomatic weapons right now.
Virtually every modern gun.
So let's say they want to ban Ar
fifteens air 15th rifles aren't even
used like the,
the,
the percentage that rifles are used in
actual shootings is so low and marginal.
It's,
it's unreal.
So then why are we focusing on that?
But okay,
so then what are most shootings?
Our handguns.
Yeah,
right.
So if we get rid of that and we got rid
of Ar for teens and then we have another
shooting happened because the army was
deadliest.
Mass shooting was Virginia Tech and he
used the hangup.
So then what happens if that happens
again?
So now what are you going to ban you?
You're going to abandon the hangup and
that's when you're stuck.
Having to confront the fact that,
okay,
either you really just want to ban all
guns or you understand that the
distinction is irrelevant,
right?
With God to get to the absolute point of
issue and why these things are happening
and focusing on the gun is doing a
disservice to the conversation.
It sounds like I'm just utilizing.
I'm using the bigger issue as a
scapegoat,
but in reality if you really sit down
and think about it,
right?
We have over 300,
close to 400 million guns in this
country and not going anywhere and
understanding that you've got to then
sit down and say to yourself,
all right,
if we're going to try to fix this issue
of gun violence or just violence in
general,
we've got to get to the root of the
issue of why people are doing it and
then understanding that.
Staying within the context of reality.
We've got to understand well in the
process,
I still have to protect myself and
because people are still gonna be able
to get their hands on guns whether
illegal or not,
and and use them to commit crimes and
the bread and people's lives.
I've got to be put in a situation to
defend against that so you can bend all
the outfit teams you want.
Doesn't mean it's going to stop somebody
from getting one on the black market.
So now,
yes,
I don't run from the fact that the ar 15
is a more powerful platform that I agree
with and I don't think it.
I don't run from that.
They're going to be people on who we
were going to be mad at me for saying
that,
but the reason why the run from it just
because that's the very reason why I
want an ar 15 when it comes to defending
my life.
I don't want it to be a fair fight
period.
I don't want to have to confront someone
with an ar 15 with a handgun if I don't
have to.
If you come in my house,
I'm not grabbing a handgun.
I am grabbing an arm,
see we have this strange thing.
It's like when people will say,
okay,
well the second amendment says the right
to bear arms and then they'll put up a
picture of,
you know,
the type of arms that existed way back
when and it's like well then we should
have the right to that because that's
what they were talking about it.
It's like this is so disingenuous.
Very disingenuous.
It's like they were also talking about
why you should be able to form a militia
and it's like the thing that we'd be
fighting against now has a lot more
power and it doesn't mean that just
because you have some guns,
you're going to be able to stop the guys
in the black trucks as you talked about
earlier,
but maybe you could defend yourself a
little bit longer and who knows what
happens with a little bit of time.
I mean fruit and be real with them.
They're still fighting in Afghanistan
and those guys over there just using AK
$47.
You get what I'm saying?
So like we can't just because we're
going to lose something that you just
lie down and do it,
you know,
and in,
in that the whole notion of like,
ah man,
I just lost my train of thought that
this idea of owning firearms to combat
the government and they think it's
preposterous,
but I'm like,
ask the people in Venezuela,
and again,
these are now the people,
at least in this current moment,
the people who say that the government
is run by Orange Hitler.
Exactly,
man.
It's really well.
Well this is a good spot.
I think changed some minds and as I said
to you before we sat down and I've never
considered myself a gun person per se.
Uh,
I'm interested in.
I'm always interested in talking about
these things,
but I do find myself now more pro gun.
It's probably not even the right phrase
to say that I've ever been in my life
and then.
But for me it has more to do with that.
I really understanding what rights are
in a much clearer way and,
and what I want
the government to do.
And,
and once you understand that,
then
yeah,
no,
it's tough.
It's tough to take other positions.
It is weakened.
So is there anything to you that when
they always say sensible gun control and
I'll always see the pro gun,
people will say,
well,
the people that always say that just
don't know what they're talking about
now I sense you're probably in that spot
because of that.
You were just saying that they do with
language.
Yeah.
So sensible gun control.
Most of the time when people say that
they actually advocate things,
we already had background checks,
things of that nature.
Right?
And then you like,
and you have other language like the
loop,
uh,
the gun show gun,
your gun show loophole.
Yeah,
let's talk about that.
That's not a loophole.
All the,
all that is,
is a private transaction.
That's all that is.
And it's just happening happening.
It just so happened to happen at a gun
show.
If you bought a gun from an actual
dealer at a gun show,
you still have to undergo a background
check.
So the when they say loophole with
saying is that if you are at a gun show,
you're not a dealer,
you can actually sell that gun at the.
If you are.
If one person's not a prohibited
possessor,
you are from the same state then?
Yes.
If they.
If there's nothing that precludes them
from owning a firearm,
legally I can sell them a gun at a gun
show.
Right.
So the only slippery part of that is
what we talked about earlier,
which is you just may not know all the
information.
So there is a,
there is,
I guess there's a little bit of a gray
area and that one is,
is that a fair in terms of the
backgrounds that you're sort of taking
somebody's word for it at that point.
When you guys meet somebody that day and
they're like,
I want to buy that gun.
And you say to that,
you asked them all the appropriate
questions.
They could be lying to you,
but that's just.
Yeah.
But then that sold in the way.
The response that they have to.
That is a universal background check,
but as I pointed out,
how do you,
how do you enforce it without a national
registry and then with that national
registry,
even with the national registry,
it doesn't stop anything,
right?
We,
we,
we tend to go down this road of just
wanting to do things to make ourselves
feel better,
but in reality name one mass shooting
that would have been prevented with a
universal background check.
No one.
Because even the people who had gone to
war,
supposed to have them,
it got them illegally.
Right?
It wasn't because there wasn't a
universal background check that stopped
them from getting,
you know,
it wasn't.
So I have to so I have to ask the
question.
I go then why are we doing this other
than just to make ourselves feel better
because it's literally doing nothing,
nothing.
And so that's why like the person who
who bought and sold the gun privately at
a,
at a gun show could have done that in
the parking lot of the gun show,
could have done it at their house before
going to the gun show.
You get what I'm saying?
But what it does is when you frame it
within the context of the gun show
loophole,
it makes it seem like it's this bizarre
where everyone comes there together and
sells illegal guns.
That's the image that's created in the
mind.
Like it's barter town.
Exactly.
Like they feed on the,
made on the ignorance of people,
right?
Because they're not.
Everybody knows that much about guns.
It's like it's one of those things.
It's like,
I don't know,
I don't know a lot about a lot of other
things that people may know a lot about.
Right.
So if you tell me something and I'm not
really researched and schooled on that
issue,
you could give me the beliefs.
I'm pretty Kooky stuff.
Yeah.
And,
and that's what I'm talking to you.
I mean,
that's what you consistently see every
time we talk about this.
And you know,
there's this other piece of it where
it's like every time a shooting happens,
you know,
there's this pile on we now we should
talk about it.
Yeah.
And then there's this other part of us
where it's because we go from one crisis
to another that there's never read it.
It seems to me at this point,
we never really have time to really ever
fully unpack any of these things.
I think.
I think there's moments like this,
but on a national level,
we're not particularly good at these
conversations.
No.
Because then what it does is just turns
into a political sparring match.
Yeah.
I mean right after the last shooting and
when,
when Dana Lotion and Rubio are on that
CNN town hall and it was,
it was amazing.
I mean the gladiatorial fests,
it,
it was a disaster.
I mean it was everything I hate about
cable news.
It was everything I hate about just the
quick bites of all of this and
flashiness and just who can we take out
right now?
It was a disaster.
And then,
and I sat and I pointed this out,
how can we have a real honest
conversation when they try to paint
program people as crazy when we say no,
the ultimate goal is to ban guns.
But then I can watch cnn live town hall
where we suggest you do realize banding
on somebody.
The amount of guns is essentially
banning all guns and the entire stadium
erupts in applause and cheers.
Yeah.
So then it goes,
Yo.
Rubio said exactly what you said.
And they started cheering even even when
confronted with the core,
because Rubio said,
look,
you want to bet on somebody that had a
gun to your me kitchen really quickly
and tell you that it's virtually all
guns.
So even when he corrected them,
so it wasn't.
They can't,
they can't,
they can't claim they will be ignorant
on it because he just explained to them
that needs banning virtually all guns
and they erupted.
So it goes,
okay,
so now you have all those programs are
like,
we just going to go back to our client.
There's no discussion.
Because while,
while we're trying to be fair,
you're ultimate goal is to try to ban
them all.
You know,
there was that moment,
I'm sure you remember this,
after the Parkland shooting,
when they had the big rally and one of
the survivors got up there and said,
we're going to come.
What was the line?
Do you remember the exact line where she
said,
basically,
we're going to come for the
semiautomatics now,
but we're going to come through
everything later.
So something to that effect them.
Yeah,
I'm slightly butcher head,
but I thought,
wow,
now now you're flat out saying and
you're just giving.
You're telling them now.
So I could see why.
You know,
I,
I see this with all my frustrations with
the left all the time.
It's like I know they're never going to
stop.
I've seen it so consistently and that's
why I'm staking out some positions,
but sometimes it's,
it's kind of sucky to have to just be
like,
well,
the people that I'm fighting against so
to speak,
they're not dealing in the same world
that I'm dealing in and I.
and that makes it more important for me
to stake out a position.
But the thing that's most frustrating
about it is the way they'll color it in
the mainstream media is that were
unreasonable.
We don't want to move on inch.
We've dug her heels in.
All we want is we don't care about
anything.
And really what it is is no,
I let you into my house and now you're
trying to take my house from me.
So get out because that's essentially
what they're saying is all right.
So they'll say,
well common sense.
That's why we hate that word.
Common sense because it cause it's
disingenuous.
It's like,
well we need common sense measures after
a shooting in another shooting happens,
we need more common sense measures.
And another shooting happened.
We need even more common sense measures.
Windows commonsense mentioned,
stopped being common sense and just
intruding on my rights and I can see
the,
you know,
you know my thing for guns to use,
free speech to me.
And it's like I can see this coming with
that give these guys took control.
You'd start seeing,
well we can have free speech,
but we need some common sense controls
around Greece,
so I.
So I do understand the position that I
tell people all the time.
I'm like,
there are over 300 federal gun laws in
this country.
I think we've been reasonable.
I think we were really truly being
unreasonable.
We wouldn't have over 300 federal gun
law and I can't even begin to tell you
how many we have on a state level.
Right?
So it's incredibly disingenuous to think
that we're just being hard,
hard assets who don't want to move one
inch on the issue.
Right.
No one's saying it should be a free for
all where we're just handing out guns to
everyone like Oprah.
Right.
I don't think anybody has a problem
inherently with background checks.
Now he's talking about universal
background checks.
That's a different thing.
But since nobody.
Since they never want to make that
distinction,
right?
No one ever knows that you can't,
you can't.
Exactly.
And then the idea of like,
you know,
we can talk about gun free zones and it
begs the question is like what does
that,
what does that sticker on when they're
going to do for me?
So now I have to make like people don't
really like to sympathize with gun
owners in a sense of like we all want
the same result,
right?
We want the killing to stop.
We want the violence to stop.
Notice I said violence and killing,
not just gun violence,
right?
Because we can't just focus on gun
violence because violence is violence.
However you die,
you die and it's bad all the way around.
But when I have to make a decision about
whether or not I potentially break a law
to go into an establishment that may or
may not cause me to need my gun at some
point,
and that's messed up.
And I know that there are a lot of
people who don't see it that way because
they don't see value in the second
amendment because they're not firearm
owners.
Right?
There are a lot of people who look at
the second amendment is useless because
they don't own firearms,
but when you have a group of people who
understand the importance of it and how
it fits into their lives and they
understand that at the end of the day
when something happens,
the only person who's going to be there
to stop it is you.
That's a big deal.
So it's not just me trying to protect a
piece of metal because I just want to
have fun with my guns.
No,
it's much bigger than that.
It's this idea that I have to rely on
myself.
You can tell me all day long,
the police are going to be there,
but they're not going to be.
They're just not.
And then,
and then you think you named were at
Parkland.
Exactly right.
So then you,
then you add kids,
family into the mix.
That ratchets it up to a whole nother
level.
So that.
What about the piece of this that just
sort of optics.
So,
you know,
every now and again you'll see a picture
of like three dudes with big ass guns at
Aaa,
an open carry.
Now I know if I was,
if I walked into Japan and three guys
came in with big ass guns on their back,
you can prototype notice why would take
notice?
And I probably leave.
I probably would,
I would just be like,
you know,
like,
and again I'm here,
I'm here in California where that would
be so,
so out of the norm.
But for the person that's living in
Texas,
you can do this.
If I was in AAA,
right?
And three guys walking in,
I probably would leave no one.
Everything that you just said there,
knowing that these guys are probably NRA
members and,
and as far as I know,
no NRA member has ever done a mass
shooting know.
Right?
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
because you see this,
all the celebrities,
Michael,
Ian Black light out on the show who's on
this rampage telling everyone that you
guys are terrorists.
I mean really that you're part of a
terrorist organization.
Okay?
And so all the other 5 million members,
but I think there is something about
some of the optics of that,
you know what I mean?
Like I would be nervous now.
I get your point would be,
well those guys are going to protect you
and the other guy walks in or whatever.
And some of that may be feelings over
facts right there,
but it just,
it just is.
The interesting thing about it that is a
big debate within the gun,
the gun community as a whole.
The idea of open carry versus concealed
carry.
I don't ever open carry except for maybe
if I'm out hunting or I'm on the range
or something like that.
But that's,
that's a personal decision.
I'm choosing my own for various reasons.
One,
sometimes I rather not have the
attention.
And tactically I liked the advantage of
having the element of surprise.
You don't know I have a gun on me,
so if I had to use it,
I'm going to be reacting.
Right?
I'm not going into a place to shoot it
up.
If somebody decides to come into a place
to shoot,
I'm going to be reacting to that.
So I need all the advantages I get from
my personal perspective.
So I want the element of surprise.
There's some people who think only
alternative.
They feel like just the mere presence of
that gun is a deterrent from anyone who
wants to come in and do some bad.
So if a guys casing out a couple of
stores in,
then ecs,
there are certain citizens in there with
long guns and some that have a hand guns
on the side of your hip,
then that's a deterrent.
I understand the alarm that people who
don't necessarily engage in interact
with fire arms get when they see people
walking around with rifles.
Right.
Even though I've never been.
I've seen a couple of people in Texas do
it and initially my gut reaction and
I'll admit was like,
what?
What's going on here?
I'm now,
I'm very versed firearms and I have a
gun too.
So at that point I actually almost
welcome it and the reason why is because
if you're going to do something,
I now get to see you attempt to do it.
You get what I'm saying?
There's a telegraph.
They are in a unique case.
Yes,
but I'm speaking from purely a personal
preference,
right?
Am I getting on the whole for anyone
else or anything like that?
Me Personally,
I would rather like to know you have it
right if I can see it,
because then I know where to focus my
attention versus me kind of being alone
to a state of complacency because of its
absence.
And then all of a sudden somebody stands
up and decides he wants to shoot the
place up.
Um,
and then I have to react to that.
but again,
that's tactics,
right?
That,
that's personal preference in that
regard.
However,
I do understand the alarm that somebody
who would have seen you three guys
walking into aaa with,
uh,
with rifles because it seems seemingly,
especially to them,
it seems like that's a bit excessive.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
If I can conceal carry a rifle,
I would because it's better at defending
me than a handgun was the only reason.
The only reason I have a handgun it was
because it's small enough for me to
conceal and it allows me to live my life
in an uninterrupted.
Otherwise I'd walk around with a rifle.
Okay.
So we can't end without doing sort of
what I think would be the big question
for everything we've talked about.
Hearing for someone that works with the
NRA and your show is on nitv and all
that.
So what is going on in America right now
that seems to be unique to our society?
We do have more shootings here than I
and I think virtually all other western
nations combined.
Um,
so.
Okay.
For you to fact check me on that if I
butchered that one.
But it does seem it's.
And even if I'm slightly.
Oh No,
no,
you're good.
You're good.
It seems that there is something
uniquely happening here now.
I would argue that there's all sorts of
mental health issues and probably a
prescription drugs and maybe non
prescription drugs and all sorts of
other stuff.
So there's a,
there were a couple of things.
So I'll try to.
I've try to keep this as concise as
possible because we are going to get
into weeds for a split second.
He got.
So first of all,
let's talk about mass shootings,
right?
Your schools,
school districts.
For instance,
I recently just read a study from
northwestern university I'm not too long
ago,
which talked about comparing the number
of school shootings back in the nineties
versus the versus today.
And what they concluded essentially was
the perception is that it's happening
more frequently,
but it's not,
it's actually on par or even less now
than it was then.
Now you can people who are going to do
like,
oh my God,
how could you possibly say that?
Google it.
It's a northwestern university.
Um,
research.
Uh,
I can't remember the actual title of the
actual research,
but we're going to grab it from you
after this guy's linked to it.
And absolutely.
So that being said,
mass shootings account for a very,
very,
very marginal percentage of shootings in
this country.
Let's start off with the overall.
So 35,
35 to 36,000
people each year die from guns,
right?
I didn't specify gun violence,
but just guns because they don't do
that.
They'll just say gun violence.
Right?
So 60 about 60 to 65 percent of those,
that 35,000
suicides.
Now what I'm not saying is we don't care
about suicides.
We do.
However,
when it comes to the idea and the issue
of somebody shooting at me that's a.
that's not.
It's not Germane.
But then even still,
if you want to make the argument,
well,
if we had less guns,
we'd have less suicides.
That's also not true because our suicide
rate is on par with every other major
country.
So if it was a case that the more guns
you have,
the more suicides will you be leading
the charge?
We don't there where there's a will.
There's a way.
Exactly right.
Even some of the more famous suicides
that we've had,
they didn't use guns.
So we sat that number aside,
which is a huge number,
65 percent,
it's huge number out of 35,
36,000.
So then you have about one to three
percent which are justifiable homicides,
that self defense,
that's including police shooting
criminals who are shooting at them,
right?
And people who use guns in self defense,
We got to set that aside because that's
not the issue we're trying to address.
So it's at that number.
So and then you have about five percent
which are accidental,
right?
Kid gets behind the gun,
pull triggers,
unfortunate,
extremely unfortunate.
However,
I believe personally half of that can
easily be addressed with more education.
So if we took the energy that we took
that we we placed,
now I'm trying to vilify guns and have
national campaigns teaching people about
gun safety,
that we'll cut that number in half
because a lot of these accidents easily
preventable,
but they're just people who have gone to
just don't know.
And so if we spend time educating those
people,
do we know what percentage of that
subset is getting those guns legally or
illegally?
Because I would imagine that a lot of
it's probably illegal,
which is why they don't know how to use
the gun in the first.
I'm not going to assume I have that
answer because I don't have that hard
number.
Um,
but,
and I would bet I do feel comfortable
assuming that as well.
Right?
Um,
and so we take that,
the accidents and set that aside,
purely homicides were looking at around
seven to 10,000
every year.
Right now,
that's a different looking number,
right?
When will be accounted for all of the,
the context here with those,
those other shootings.
Now the vast majority,
I'd say close to 80 percent that I've
read in a couple of articles of those
homicides are happening in the inner
cities of our country.
Right?
So then reasoning goes,
all right,
so let's look at those inner cities and
it's,
look at the dynamics there,
right?
You have low jobs,
lack of economic opportunity,
storied households and a narco economy
that warrants that warrants but creates
the necessity for this type of violence.
So if we dealt with the socioeconomic
aspects of what's going on in those
areas right to we really have a gun
problem,
just think about it.
I know I know other communities filled
with black people,
they have guns,
they don't have the same level of
violence because I only say black people
because most people associate the inner
city with with black people.
Right?
But the reason why we had that high
level of concentration of violence,
it's because of the conditions in those
environments.
And then even within those communities
there are.
The vast majority of people in those
committees are good people and it's a
very minor group of people who are
creating a large number of the violence.
Right?
So there's something to be said.
Do we really have a gun problem or do we
have a social economic suicide problem
in this country?
Because at the end of the day,
this 35 to 36,000
that people assuming is all gun violence
by way of homicides,
people shooting at other people to kill
them.
It's not the case.
We're looking at closer to seven to
10,000
if that.
So if you take those numbers and you
compare them other countries,
then how does it look?
Could it be continued?
Yeah.
Well I'm so glad that we finally did
this and we will definitely do this
again because I absolutely.
This story and everything we've talked
about here is just going to continue.
I mean these are the battles that we're
now fighting on many fronts related to
the constitution and free speech and
free expression and your ability to,
to own your life and all that stuff.
And that's all we ask is.
This is a.
let me see.
Well I'll say one last thing.
Yeah,
people are,
there are a lot of people.
It was like,
why do you feel the need to carry a gun?
Why?
I like the chances of you needing to use
that gun to protect yourself one
percent.
And the answer I have for that is this.
You may be right.
The chance of me need to care to
actually use my gun to defend myself.
Maybe really slim,
maybe one percent,
but if that one percent happens,
it's 100 percent of everything.
The consequences are 100 percent and
that's why it's so important.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
that's how you and to show you know,
you maybe we'll do this next time.
Maybe we'll bring you on with someone on
some of the other side of the issues on
this.
I will tell them what that conversation
sounds like.
A plan.
All right.
For Moron coli on check them out on
twitter.
Mr Leon nor.